retailers will likely ring up record
sales on this the last Saturday of the
holiday shopping season with a surge in
last-minute gift buyers today is
expected to be the biggest shopping day
of the year even surpassing Black Friday
the National Retail Federation says
holiday shoppers will spend 730 billion
dollars this holiday season that's about
four percent more than last year Tom
Hansen joins us with more on the mad
dash to snag the perfect gift
Tom good morning good morning Jeff well
move over Black Friday here comes Super
Saturday the single busiest shopping day
of the year and get this nearly half of
the country is expected to hit the
streets and the internet for their last
chance to score major deals while
putting gifts under the tree it's the
height of the holiday rush as the days
dwindle to Christmas and Hanukkah the
National Retail Federation says 148
million shoppers will go down to the
wire to complete their holiday gift
lists I just got vacations I've got the
time major retailers are expected to
generate an estimated thirty four
billion dollars today as they extend
ours and offer last-minute deals from
Macy's and Target to Best Buy an Apple
many stores around the country are
opening early and closing late Kohl's
will be open from now all the way
through 6:00 p.m. on Christmas Eve even
Petsmart is getting in on the action buy
two get one free on all dog toys or
treats but for millions of online
shoppers who procrastinate today may
turn into panic Saturday with more than
two billion packages delivered this
holiday season FedEx UPS and other
delivery services are expecting delays
to some on-time deliveries which could
cost shoppers extra fees to get their
gifts before the big day you'll still be
able to get things but you're likely
gonna have to pay for it and it's gonna
be by air which is the most expensive
products they offer now delivery
services blame the delays on bad weather
they also say that since Thanksgiving
came later this year there's been a
higher demand over fewer days and Dana I
think that this says a lot about the
American shopper there's
either the procrastinator or people who
get that stuff done on time I admittedly
am waiting for something from Target
that better get there fair enough I need
it to get there Tom thank you
you